today we're going to talk about an enlarged prostate and urinary changes and I'm
specifically talking about BPH benign
prostatic hypertrophy which is in a
large prostate as well as lots lower
urinary tract symptoms and that would be
frequent urination increased urgency you
have to go have to go but can't
especially if you have a full bladder
you pee more at night than you do during
the day the stream is poor you have
dribbling and there's an incomplete
voiding now if you do a search on these
problems you're gonna find that this is
associated with DHT this is a very
powerful form of testosterone and I've
done quite a few videos on this as well
but there's an interesting study that
came out I want to talk about it it's a
randomized placebo-controlled study with
114 men over 24 months that were given
DHT therapy which is that powerful
testosterone treatment and none of them
had an increase in prostate growth nor
do they have any type of inflammation
now that is conflicting information but
so is the fact that as you age your
testosterone goes down so how can an
enlarged prostate be associated with too
much estrogen specifically this one
right here and we know the size of the
prostate increases as a man ages not to
mention they have all sorts of urination
problems in fact 50% of men when they
reach the age of 60 have an enlarged
prostate and 90% of men when they
reached the age 90 have an enlarged
prostate so why is this and how could it
possibly be DHT and actually can't be
DHT as the cause now one of the causes
could be excessive amounts of estrogen
because as you decrease testosterone
estrogen will go up but there's
something else that I want to talk about
that has a huge connection huge
association and that is the metabolic
syndrome
what is the metabolic syndrome metabolic
syndrome is a collection of various
symptoms central obesity that means you
have fat in your midsection hypertension
high cholesterol impaired glucose which
may not show up in blood sugars right
away you just may have a difficult time
going from one meal to the next without
needing a snack low testosterone and
low-grade inflammation which would be
stiffness arthritis knees shoulders back
now what's really behind the metabolic
syndrome is this right here
hyperinsulinemia that is too much
insulin in your blood and insulin is
anabolic now testosterone is also anabolic which means it makes things grow
but insulin also makes things grow as in
the prostate and there are several
studies which I'll put down below that
show a significant high fasting insulin
level with DPH and lots the reason why
you have an enlarged prostate and all
the urination problems is actually not
this it is just too much insulin now if
you're new to my channel and you're not
aware of the solution then I put some
links down below of the exact videos
that you need to watch because it is
actually very easy to start seeing
changes in your urination and even
potentially your prostate what you need to
do is get on a healthy keto plan and
start intermittent fasting that is what's
going to address the underlying root
problem right here and if you're a
little hesitant or skeptical about this
try for three days and notice what
happens to your urination especially at
night you'll see some really great
changes so if you're new to my channel I
put the first video right here check it
out